[Music]
hello friends i'm so happy to be here
talking about developer productivity
with you and i'm going to talk about 10
different tips and tools that you can
adopt in 15 minutes or less each so
these are a bunch of little ideas that
maybe you've heard of maybe haven't if
you want to adopt them it's not a lot of
effort you can just try something out so
no big commitments here and a bunch of
things to choose from
let's get started we're going to go
through the 10 tips and you'll see a few
examples along the way
first of all let's talk about the
command prompt
shell terminal whether you're on windows
or mac or linux
we're always as a developer working with
a command line there's all sorts of
things we have to do to get our jobs
done
but if you open up your terminal and it
looks like this
or you open up your command prompt on
windows and it looks like
basiccmd.exe
that's a problem you're missing a huge
opportunity for a very very powerful
system to do a whole bunch more
so let's look at another option over
here we have my terminal on my mac os
here and notice there's some colors
going on
if i type stuff like ctrl c you can see
that there's a little red arrow instead
of a green arrow that means that last
command failed let's go over to a more
interesting directory one that is say a
github repository notice the prompt
changes and over you can see git colon
master it actually shows you the branch
the status of the
get in this repository that we're in
we do an ls we get colors for like
directories versus files all sorts of
cool stuff there
there's great auto complete so for
example if i want to go back to my
history and just see all the things i've
done with brew i just hit brew and then
up arrow and it just shows me all the
commands that i previously run by using
the arrow key that start with brew
that's fantastic
and you even get autocomplete for higher
order things such as
get so if i i know i want to branch i
think or something start with a b i hit
tab and it says oh you could bisect or
you could branch and i could even tab
over and hit that one so yep that's
actually the one that i wanted
so this is oh my z shell
the recommendation is maybe check out
only oh my z shell but the real
recommendation here is to just look at
some alternatives
so for mac os and for linux i strongly
recommend on my z shell i think it's
really really great there's many other
options as well
if you're on windows you can use oh my
posh and this actually works in other
places notice this
part right here all these colors
you've got the green you've got actually
here's the get repository and the
changes
all the stuff going on here so really
really nice
this works on powershell for example so
oh my z shell doesn't
all right so first recommendation is get
a very proper shell that is built for
developers to do developer things and
really you're going to be super happy
finally if you're on windows don't use
command prompt and maybe don't even use
straight powershell directly use the new
windows terminal and see the link at the
bottom it's much better than what you
have before
number two security if you run a web app
you want to make sure that your web app
is secure well how do you do that
you can go check in with owasp the open
web application security project they
have all these
recommendations and
top 10 security holes or problems that
we've seen over time but how do you keep
up with them how do you keep them in
your app
well there's this really cool project
called secure a package called secure or
secure pi
over in the python space and if you're
not a python person just hang tight
what you can do is very simply create
one of these secure headers and you just
go to your framework for example here in
this tween section you write these three
lines of code and you say secure headers
secureheaders.framework.pyramid
upgrade this response to a secure one or
with flask or with django it supports
many many python frameworks
and if you do this
come back over here and have a quick
look we're doing that over on talk
python training let's do a request and
we'll see what headers we get back from
our request
we look at our headers notice that
there's 12 responses and we get things
like strict transport security
x frame embedding options to prevent
people from embedding our responses
no sniff uh restricted referrer policies
and so on all of these are
put into our request automatically by
secure pi
again if you're not a python person
maybe you're in dotnet you work with
asp.net there's something like this
called nwebsec and you can see this link
here to a blog post by scott hanselman
that talks about it
if you're in another technology there's
likely a library like this you can just
plug in and add all these secure headers
that make your website well more secure
number three
we saw the command prompt well you
shouldn't
only use command prompts maybe if you're
doing git you should think about using
some kind of gui i know a lot of people
want to just keep it straight simple and
easy and just use the command prompt but
there's a lot of things you can see with
a proper ui so i recommend that you
check out sourcetree sourcetree is a git
client a get gui
and it seems to have almost all of the
features of get so if you want to do
pushes rebases and all sorts of you know
sort of more advanced types of things
all those are still there it doesn't
hide very much from you but you get the
benefit of having a lot more visual
information
you can also check out github desktop
that works on all the os's if you're
working with an ide like pycharm or
visual studio they come with built in
get so consider using that there like
for in this example you can see this
commit is going to add a function can
evade to this class here
that's way better than just you know git
add dot git commit dash m i think i
remember what i did you can see exactly
what you did
and even with the visual studio and
pycharm or intellij you can access
things like pull requests and check them
out check out the what's going to happen
play with it and then decide whether or
not you're going to prove it so all
sorts of good stuff visual studio code
has it built in as well so
be sure to remember your ui's forget
speaking of get
have you ever
created a fork of a repository so you
find something you like so for example
here we have the secure project that i
was just telling you about before i
forked it over to my personal github
repository
but
as that library the original changes
you're going to be behind and maybe you
don't want to be
traditionally what you've had to do is
you've had to go to the command prompt
you've had to go and add an origin and
then pull the origin and then check out
the main branch and then merge the
origin into the main and then you commit
that back and uh
just to keep it in sync so github
recently added a fetch upstream to all
forks
so if i go to my fork page it says oh
your fork is two commits behind click
fetch and merge and we will just catch
it up so if you have a forked
brand if you have a forked repo that you
really care about
be sure to do this because it'll keep
you in sync much easier than before
error logging and reporting
you're probably logging right in your in
your technology
python.net java whatever it is they all
come with built-in logging frameworks
and my experience is they're almost all
bad i don't know why but they just kind
of seem clumsy to use
they're a little bit extra work or
they're over designed or you name it so
i encourage you to check out some cool
external logging packages that you can
bring in so in the python world i use
something called logbook which is a
really simple nice way to create
rotating files for your log files and
add extra info another really popular
one is log guru or law guru and really
really nice and regardless of what
technology you're working in i'm sure
that there are some much better logging
frameworks but also
it's not just about putting messages
into files it's about notifications and
tracking and categorization and stuff so
look into
services like sentry
where you can do a little integration
with your site if there's an error or
other types of information that'll
automatically get saved at sentry then
you'll get a notification hey there was
an error in your site and you can go see
the log you can see the
trace back or
the stack trace and figure out what's
going on you'll see all the variables
maybe who was logged in super super
helpful so
better logging with better packages
don't just do the default usually and
then you can actually add some services
on for notification and
much just much better stuff so you
actually know what's going on in your
site
speaking of sites you want to keep them
secure it used to be that you'd have to
pay 200 and get approved for an ssl
certificate that's completely silly
those those days are long gone let's
encrypt is now a thing that
automatically generates free ssl
certificates
so if you've got a website it needs to
have ssl
google is
treating websites that are not secure
well that's not secure and they're not
showing up as well in search results
they're being looked down upon in the ui
of things like chrome and so on so you
really want to have ssl even if you
don't really need it for your site i
mean maybe you're not actually storing
anything secure
but the infrastructure the web is
starting to expect it so you want it
it's adding let's encrypt your site if
it's hosted on linux is incredibly easy
you install
basic you basically add a repository for
the universe you say get app to get
install certbot python three certbot
nginx and then all you have to do is say
certbot dash dash nginx it looks at all
the domains that are set up under say
nginx and it'll suggest creating and
maintaining and automatically renewing
certificates for that
it supports other servers other than
nginx just happens to be the example i
have here so you can see the docs down
at the bottom there
but if you've got a website and you're
in charge of running the server make
sure that you use something like let's
encrypt so that it's secure
this one is a very fun one
if you want to have unit tests for a web
app web api something like that
one thing you can do is sit down and
write a whole bunch of tests and you
probably should do that you should be
testing your code of course
but there's a really really simple
technique almost a trick it's not really
a trick it's a technique or a shortcut
maybe it's the best word
for
really quickly
just deciding if your site mostly works
because when it breaks
it's not like well the box is off to the
side or this piece is hidden now usually
what happens when a website breaks is it
crashes the server 500 error and it
breaks hard
so
if your site has a site map and it
likely does because you want it to look
good and you want it to present itself
to google right this is an xml document
that
shows what urls are there
you can leverage the sitemap to
basically request every single page on
your site as part of an integration test
and decide is it working or is it not
working
so let's check that out over here so
over at talk python to me the podcast
website we have
a site map as you can imagine
these have lots of pages for example the
talk python training one has about 4 000
pages listed in its sitemap
and what we can do in this one is we can
go and just write a very small
test here that will go and request the
sitemap then use a little xpath xml dom
stuff to figure out what all the urls
are convert them from global because you
don't want to request the production one
you want to request your test one and
then just run it so we go over here and
just run this test individually you can
see down at the bottom here
it's just going and hitting every single
one of these pages and it's cranking
through it i think there's probably
three or four hundred here for this site
and every one of them passed so hey
looks like your test pass
how long did that take 10 seconds not
very long at all but it's a really
simple and easy way to
make sure the site is going and what's
cool is when you add something new
the sitemap is updated right you add
something in the database it regenerates
the sitemap because you want that to
show up for search well you can just
piggyback on that and make sure that
those pages keep working all the time
through continuous integration and so on
so super super easy technique here to
just
run
a simple request against every page that
you have on your site and make sure that
it well it doesn't break
here's a simple code at least in python
set up some test code
get a hold of the
sitemap.xml and then as we saw just use
xml processing to pull out the urls and
then request every single one of those
individually if they all work with a 200
or 201 or something like that maybe even
a 302 they don't do 404s and they didn't
don't do 500s you're in a really good
place
all right
somewhat related to the ssl thing google
is also treating sites that are not fast
and don't provide a good user experience
less well as in de-ranking them in
search and so on and one really really
important site that you can check
is called
pagespeed insights this is from google
you can put your url in here
and if you've never done this prepare
yourself to be somewhat disappointed so
for example i put in talk python
training here
that website responds
usually from a request hitting the
server until it goes out the other side
usually 10 to 30 milliseconds and i
thought well of course google is going
to think this site is fast that's
fantastic right
nope i put that in there and i think you
can see the little scale here at the
bottom i think i got a 55 that's the
bottom end of slow to average like whoa
this is a problem how is this possible
well it's possible because it doesn't
take into just the server response time
for websites
you know what it looks at is well if you
serve our large images and they have to
be resized and let's say on a phone well
how much time is that going to take and
well how long is it until the javascript
renders the front end bits the user
actually sees that and is there a lot of
javascript that's slowing down the page
and so on and so on so there's many many
different things
that you can
work on and if you scroll down and you
put your pa your site in here and you
scroll down this page you'll see tons of
concrete
recommendations so i got my 55 or
whatever it was
and i was disappointed but i went
through the recommendations and i didn't
take all of them but i took many of them
and now you can see
99 that is super super cool i still have
a little work to do on mobile they added
some new tests that i got to come back
to i suppose but really if you have a
website and you want it to rank high and
have a good user experience this is
incredibly helpful
if you have to install software
do you go and download it if i want
python do i go to python.org and
download it if i want node do i go and
download node and install it i can
what if there's an update how do i know
there's an update how do i perform that
update right so i go download it again
and install it over top the old one now
don't do that
use something like homebrew if you're on
mac os homebrew is fantastic because you
can say brew install
mongodb and now you have mongodb plus
time there's updates it'll just
automatically update it for you brew
install python will give you the latest
python 3.
if you're not on mac os maybe you're on
linux well linux has it built in right
this is the one place
where
linux has had this all the time right
we've got apt on ubuntu and so on
so nothing to do if you're on linux but
if you're on windows you can't use
homebrew and windows this is not a very
common
idea but i would recommend you check out
chocolaty chocolatey is the same idea
you can say i want to install this
library or this package or this
application and it'll download it and
it's dependencies and keep it up to date
for you
speaking of dependencies
number 10 the last one
if you've got a web app or
any kind of app really but
it's super important that you keep the
dependencies up to date and fresh but
especially something that has an open
port on the internet it's even more
important
so let's go through what this might look
like well you can say
i have tools that i just installed so
instead in python i would say pip
install pyramid to get the pyramid web
framework no big deal it's great it
gives me the latest
well unless you've already got it
installed then you get the message the
requirement is already satisfied even if
it's old even if it's out of date no you
have it installed
no big deal i'll just add the dash dash
upgrade that'll get me the latest
nope
it does give you the latest but
there's a bunch of dependencies that
themselves you know when you install
pyramid it transverses the dependencies
and installs those
those also have to be separately updated
now what
what if there's a security issue like
what if there's a vulnerability in
pyramid i need to fix it right away will
i get a notification or do i have to
remember to do this all the time
no big deal you pin your version and
github will give you updates
yes
but do you get
regular feature updates or only
important updates about bug
security bugs right
so you can use dependabot which is now
part of github they were acquired by
github and they will look at your
requirements for your different
technologies whether it's node.js or
dotnet or python or whatever and it will
tell you when there are new dependencies
and actually do prs over to your
repository so if you've got something on
github and you have some kind of
requirements file go ahead and add
depend a bot to that that's great you
can also use pip.io i kind of like how
they work better but they're they're
paid service and they're not part of
github so you can decide and of course
that one's just for python right
dependable is more broad
right well that is it those are the 10
tips
thank you thank you for taking the time
to watch i hope you found them useful
if you want to follow me on twitter
follow me over there i'm at m kennedy
if you want to learn more about these
kind of things especially with the
python bent check out talk python to me
one of the podcasts that i run that does
like deep
long-form conversations and then python
bytes which is like a weekly newsletter
with analysis in the python and
technology space and of course if you
want to learn things about python and
that ecosystem check out talk python
training with that
thanks so much it's been great to be
here with you